when I fall onstage I'm in my own world
the only thing going through my head is
that nothing else exists but the trick
I'm doing in that current moment the
yo-yo flings up in the air goes under my
leg it's being bounced back and forth
between the strings with being sideways
horizontally the way I express myself on
stage comes out and I love that feeling
where you could kind of be free Boop
when I'm not on stage I'm a graphic
designer
living in Los Angeles most of the year
I'm just like any typical recent grad
trying to figure out what to do with
their life but come summer I'm preparing
to be the best yo-yo performer at the
world yo-yo contest my name is Ben Conde
I am a professional yo-yo player and I'm
ranked number one in North America and
the offstring division I think people
think yo-yos are incredibly simple but
it's gone a long way since being a toy
that goes up and down and now there's
all these new elements to it
many people don't know there are five
styles of yoyo there's one handed yoyo
there's two handed responsive yo-yo two
handed unresponsive yo-yo counterweight
Helio and off string yo-yo which is what
I specialize in it's riskier it's the
riskiest division in my opinion because
of the fact that it can fall off the
string for the past 19 years I've been
working on yo-yo tricks trying to figure
out what tricks to do that's half the
battle because you're performing those
tricks to music one of the hardest parts
is telling a story through your music
giving the right energy and work on
making something flow it's a lot of hard
work that you put into it in any split
second of losing focus it seems like a
whole years of work goes the weight I
have to prove that I'm not going to
waste audience's time and for people to
respond positively towards it that I
like can't thank the sport enough
I started playing yo-yo when I was 4
years old and it's something I care
about it's not something I do for money
like it's a toy it's a toy at simplest
form and I just happened to be competing
with it for a really long time and
spending a lot of time learning in the
end it's something that makes me feel
comfortable
it keeps me youthful it reminds me of
what I would be playing with as a kid
you